nailed it
when it comes to filming in the
multiverse things can get pretty weird
on set and you know what that means
bloopers from elizabeth olsen to
benedict cumberbatch to benedict wong
we've got the most fun moments of all
your marvel faves from behind the scenes
amid the madness of the multiverse i
love that one
number one work or play on a marvel set
it's usually both elizabeth olsen had an
intense go during wandavision so when
she was letting loose in the multiverse
of madness she really went for it or was
she losing it
inside her green screen studio rig the
actress was as giddy as a kid in an
amusement park okay poll time is she
making marvel movie magic or is she on a
tilt-a-whirl number two
that's some awkward positioning filming
in the multiverse means the sets have to
be creative sometimes
which leads to crew members hanging out
in some unusual spots while filming but
rachel mcadams the good canadian she is
went out of her way to make sure she
made some somewhat proper introductions
sorry hi hello i'm rachel i'm sebastian
nice to meet you
number three
words can trip up even the most
professional of actors benedict
cumberbatch was not an expert in words
after some very long days in the
multiverse
we can't blame him for having a hard
time getting all those words out though
all this geography speak had him
tripping what do you want with a
multiverse in the mirror and the
americas
all of them
all the little islands too just all of
it number four
when fans go out of control chaos ensues
all right so how many bits of leaves are
we guessing flew into the scarlet witch
and america chavez actors mouths both of
them really struggled with their mega
fan co-star and to make it all worse the
mess on set is all the fault of the fan
number five practice does make perfect
elizabeth olsen wasn't ready to quit
until she knew she'd put her absolute
best foot forward nothing less would do
i hated that let me do it again let me
do it again let me do it again it seems
like olson was influenced by her co-star
catherine hahn during one division
one more one more one more one more
still wrong ready number six sometimes
they just can't help themselves while
they keep their language much cleaner on
screen the bts footage is evidence that
there were some curses being thrown
around on a regular basis under
them don't
get up everyone number seven
doctor strange is tough but he's not
unbreakable
that button's coming down and evidently
neither is his costume who knew benedict
cumberbatch was signing up for days of
being roughly handled on set number
eight the struggles are real anyone
who's worn a cape knows that they're not
all it's cracked up to be especially in
terms of practicality i'm stuck
clearly this is something elizabeth
olsen knows all too well i
can't get up
number nine
well this made for an awkward farewell
we can't imagine rachel mcadams was
feeling too nice after so rudely being
shut out by the set doors what did she
ever do to them hi
bye
bye
number 10
is it a mic or is it a weapon the boom a
powerful and integral mic to use on sets
but then there were times that it just
got in the way
oh you got my head there
you better not mess with wanda's hair
boom mike number 11.
those are some speedy actors
there was no worry about looking both
ways here never see me be set so quickly
we're guessing this was one of the many
very long days on set it's over number
12.
who can blame her
she is the scarlet witch
feisty as can be when she wasn't giving
off powerful witch vibes lizzie olson
brought the queen of the jungle number
13. it's really never a dull moment with
this team as soon as the cameras stopped
rolling cumberbatch was on
three two one
we are not sure what this was about but
really it's like he just never runs out
of energy
number 14. everyone danced their way
through filming from wang to wanda to
strange to america everyone had their
required dance time to get down in the
multiverse
number 15.
no one could keep it together all the
time and it was definitely tougher than
expected to keep a straight face without
corpsing i didn't like that not so
serious when the cameras aren't rolling
are they
as much as we love the drama they bring
to the screen seeing all the fun moments
and slip ups that happen during the
filming process make us appreciate this
mad multiverse crew even more who do you
think messed up the most takes on set
[Music]